and we've got to keep on showing up we
gotta keep on voting we've got to keep
our foot off the gas all the way to
Victory
I'm like Ricky Bobby
I don't come to lose
you can wake up tomorrow morning and see
that the news Senator but a great state
of Georgia
[Music]
yeah we're heading to Forsyth County
Georgia and it's known to be a fairly
rad leaning historically it's got some
some interesting racial history for many
years it was said that African Americans
were not really welcome in Forsyth
County Oprah Winfrey went down to and
actually filmed one of her Oprah
segments we bring you today to Forsyth
County Georgia which in the past few
weeks has gained the reputation of being
a hotbed of racism I think a lot of that
has changed for the better in recent
years it's gotten a lot more diverse
certainly one of the fastest growing
Atlanta counties but as diverse it is
it's still about two-thirds Republican
uh one-third Democrat so
one would think that if Herschel is
going to you know win today he's really
got to run up the score on places like
Forsyth County
how do you think you'll vote and what
what makes you lean that direction I
will definitely be voting for Herschel
Walker no doubt in my mind
these very pro-american what values do
you support that that he you think he
represents pro-life
control the Border what's going on right
now is just outrageous or not does not
have a clue
what the average Georgian is going
through economically
[Music]
you mind sharing who do you voted for
sure so um I'm a Christian so the reason
why I'm voting for The Republican is
because I think his vote is going to be
more consequential when the big issues
come up like abortion like this entity
of marriage this is really a almost more
of a vote against Raphael Warnock yeah
and more generally a vote against the
Democratic party platform listen I'm in
college I work for the Democrats in
Georgia and they just gone so far in
focusing social issues and that's for me
it's it's just frustrating because I got
real things to worry about gotta buy a
car I gotta buy a house I gotta for your
family well these guys are just playing
political games talking about political
correctness telling me as a Latino that
I cannot say Latino I have to say latinx
so I just vote for a big moral issues
and also my paycheck thanks for your
help
foreign to Gwinnett County
which is a little bit more of a swing
County a little bit less uh Republican
oriented so uh
as we're off
what brings you out today if you don't
mind sharing who you voted for and and
why
Warnock
and why is that because I think he's a
better person he care about the people
and Health Care is a very important and
women's right you know women have a
right to choose
I voted for Raphael Warnock and I will
say it is really cool having grown up in
Georgia which is you know
characteristically historically a very
red State it's cool to see this kind of
social change and it just showed me
there's a lot of forward-think thinking
people in Georgia a lot of progressives
especially younger people and slipping
Georgia Blue has had a big impact on the
country's sort of national politics you
know what what changes for the better
have you seen in terms of policy and
attitudes and whatnot I think a lot more
people are becoming aware of systemic
inequalities in our society about things
like you know civil rights women's
Liberties all of these sort of hot
button issues that people are really
passionate about
[Music]
I'm here at the election night party
tonight we're waiting for the polls to
close we have about 30 minutes left the
race can be very close
the energy in the room is really
starting to build up as early vote
tallies come in the results aren't
shocking Warnock is leading the way but
strategists are warning election day
results are still being counted right
now those typically favor Republicans
it's looking like it's going to be a
very close night
[Music]
breaking news right now at 11 the race
is called a decisive victory for Senator
Rafael Warnock Senator Rafael Warnock
defeated Republican Challenger Herschel
Walker in the state's hotly contested
runoff election
it is my honor to honor the four most
powerful words
spoken in a democracy
the people have spoken
election days it's like the Super Bowl
for us is political reporters right you
get up in the morning you got the
adrenaline rushing okay and this was a I
mean just a consequential race right you
had two you know celebrities in Georgia
running for Senate and I mean there was
a lot of excitement on both ends the
race had to go to a runoff after neither
candidate was able to get the 50
threshold so it was a really big deal
the Republicans have had this Ironclad
grip for Generations down here and now
it's I mean is it your sense that it's a
purple State now yeah well I mean I was
talking to a few strategists at the
election night party you know they were
saying listen it's very clear that this
could be a Battleground State they
pointed at the room there were so many
members of the press in the room it's
clear that the race has caught the
attention of the country but yeah
Democrats really show that they could
have a shot if they have a good
candidate they can win elections
just before this election President
Biden asked the DNC to move South
Carolina to the front of the line I was
speaking to someone on Sunday night when
I asked them hey what messages does that
send to to voters in Georgia
particularly ahead of this midterm
election and he said hey it shows that
these voters matter down here absolutely
I think you know Biden realized that
when he ran for president in 2020 that
you know black voters can really shift
an election he was kind of down under
and Clyburn came out in South Carolina
voices support for him and the race
really shifted so I think the Democratic
party understands that if they can
motivate black voters to come out and
come out hard for their candidates they
can win elections now the midterms have
finally ended I mean what happens next
do you think I mean 2024 starts in
Earnest and looks like the pathway goes
leaves now through the peach state this
race has huge implications
24 you know I think the Republican Party
within the state is really going to have
to look and see you know how are they
going to choose candidates a Republican
strategist told me that this might have
been the race that really broke Donald
Trump once and for all if they align
themselves with Trump you know they
could probably count on Georgia being a
Battleground State a purple State
probably means that that if you're a
2024 aspirin you got to kind of change
your posture a little bit right your
behavior Republicans now are seeing that
the election denialism is really
off-putting for a lot of Voters and it
seems like they're looking forward to
candidates who can kind of you know move
beyond that they're looking at DeSantis
they're looking at the governor Larry
Hogan they're looking at Governor Lynn
Younkin the Republican party is really
going to have to decide Within These
coming months you know what do they want
24 to look like do they want it to be
another repeat of trump or do they want
to move forward with someone like Rhonda
Sanchez
foreign
[Music]